but i assure you i'm just a regular guy
and
i'm here to show you a good time
i want us to have fun together
to explore each other and what does that
sound pleasing to
not to worry reggae your saturday night
live debut had no complaints from us
and oh excuse me
adu you have an eyelash
make a wish
my wish was rated r the bridgeson star
clearly had a great time poking fun at
the show's massive popularity
especially those much talked about love
scenes the show that made everyone turn
to their moms and say
you know what never mind i don't think
we should watch this together
always staying up to date on current
events snl kicked off the night by
addressing the legal battle with britney
spears and her conservatorship
and i am not trying to send people
subliminal messages
through my videos
chloe feynman played britney spears as a
talk show host with ted cruz as a guest
mocking his cancun debacle earlier in
the week i'm in a little bit of hot
water
which i'm told is a thing no one in
texas has
another standout moment was this group
sing-along to olivia rodrigo's driver's
license
we're about to get the bridge of our
lives
which olivia reacted to on twitter
writing quote driver's license
snl sketch is the best birthday present
ever i'm shaking
and musical guest bad bunny performed
his new single la noche dianoche
accompanied
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
of course the variety show couldn't end
the night without one more bridgeton
sketch
hey how you doing i'm richie the
intimacy coordinator
why would you think we're playing
brother and sister yeah i don't know
it's netflix i got some dark stuff on
there you know what i mean
the cast imagined reggae's worst case
scenario on set
um why are they green oh so they could
uh green screen in someone else's nips
thoughtful but um no thank you you sure
cause there's some
there's actually something to this we
could green screen in a guy's nipples
and then we could
play this on any network no
but in reality phoebe denver told et
bridgeton's intimacy coaches are nothing
like these two
well we've had an intimacy coach um
which i've never had before on a job
which is amazing to work with so she's
great um
we rehearse everything almost like a
stunt um
but yeah it's lucky to have someone like
reggae that i work with who we get on
really well with and
we get on really well and yeah we just
make it fun
and easy so it's great